votar votar dos outros é muito obrigado
porque estar em pé e andar em honra a
polícia turca pública também está aqui
por exemplo é um prazer para nós
partilhar um pouco daquela que é a nossa
estratégia digital experience é e
criatividade desequilibrado pegas
espero que nesta nesta pequena viagem
sky ai eu conseguimos fazer
eu sou secretário joão moura faz parte
da minha imprensa e relações públicas da
polícia de segurança pública
posso perguntar daqui da planta e
quantas pessoas seguem a psp no facebook
mais sucesso do que eu pensava
obrigado nós o nosso agradecimento por
conseguir apenas pelo facebook principal
o principal pilar onde assenta a nossa
estratégia digital aprendiz com o
princípio de robert peu é uma questão
mais uma histórica marvel lista é em que
eu fui fundador do policiamento de
proximidade
vocês passarem aqui nas ruas no porto
veio na questão da escola segura e
idosos em segurança e comércio seguro
tam exceto policiamento de proximidade
no terreno o que nós fizemos no facebook
é tão só passar essa proximidade no
terreno de segurança para as pessoas de
proximidade para rede digital com
algumas campanhas criativas outras mais
informativas e preventivas mas sempre
nesta neste contexto de chamaria
facebook proximidades do hotel é também
treinou era o time celeste antiguidade
pública piso e ao título histórico de
chã vale saúde pública ainda publica a
da polícia este é o princípio é
inspirador patrulha da polícia de
segurança pública tanto proximidade e em
gaitán são dois princípios fundamentais
para nós
alguns uma instituição hierarquizada
mais rígida é podem questionar como é
que se pode estar no recurso especial o
estatal e ter 531 mil seguidores
é eu a minha resposta é só podemos
alcançar este número de seguidores
se tivermos um raio ou seja com
criatividade
opção era ainda que ela quer informação
normal do do profissional da polícia
segurança pública seja apreensões de
armas apreensões de droga cortes trazem
informações sobre eventos e informações
sobre novos crimes
o girico é eu também aparece e mas não
for forma criativa é a mensagem não
passa para a criatividade
as operações de fiscalização rodoviária
podem ser uma experiência em que é tarde
para alguns será que você sabe fazer uma
operação stop da psp vai mostrado uma
viatura policial
dois polícias
[Música]
a amanco bahia no pré-sal stop
não seja agressivo ou ofensivo que foi
isso não faça idéia é vender os nervos
androni pouco seja afável e cubo branco
eu não saio daqui sem senha já estava em
pois vamos todos lanchar calma com
paciência então rafael mas pelo menos o
uncharted a faixa pessoal sexual a
princípio teve não leva jeito
isso foi uma forma criativa e que nós
pegarmos num não chamar nunes e maria
digital influência mas em portugal eu
penso que o pobre de de pessoas figuras
públicas se pode dizer com mais rigor
será talvez cristiano ronaldo cristina
ferreira e no marco
não é tal modo usar a pessoa mas sim
colaborar com ela com um guião nós
mostramos às pessoas o que fazer eo que
não fazer uma operação de fiscalização
rodoviária é e pelo menos pelo riso pelo
moura conseguimos ter de fato engagement
e e feedback muito positivo dos nossos
idosos
os antigos chan parâmetros de
comunicação emissor receptor hoje já
estão completamente desatualizados
é a que entre emissor e receptor um sem
número de fatores que tornam uma
mensagem pouco perceptível a outra a iss
também querem passar a mesma mensagem
tenho uma empresa uma instituição uma
uma agência essa mensagem não foi
passada de forma diferente não chega o
setor
caminhamos para este nao eh os dados
apontam que em 2020 para 55 milhões de
dólares marrons e 4.5 milhões estarão
nas redes sociais
portanto todas as marcas todas as
instituições receberam este paradigma é
estamos aqui por business school que tem
precisamente formações superiores é a
estratégia digital e em social media
a polícia de segurança pública através
do do chapéu da segurança é tem de estar
nas redes têm de estar próximo das
pessoas de forma informativa entanto vai
ser criatividade de corrupção
é policial para prestar nos prestado
pelos médicos dizem que portugal é um
país pequeno os números nos mostram
números mostram isso isto foi isso foi
um printscreen aceitassem uma duas
semanas graças ao menos 20 alunos já não
temos 525 mil já tem us 531 mil
é estamos no pódio nas redes sociais
policiais no mundo é esse lugar é may
peri em primeiro lugar polícia nacional
do de nós colombianos mais por uma
questão demográfica densidade
populacional e do próprio evento por
estratégia digital tanto a frente neste
caso da polícia nacional de espanha gnr
francesa entre outros
se encararmos a psp como uma marca
institucional é aqui alguns jogos
princípios podem adaptar desde logo
somos um pilar da segurança interna 22
mil homens e mulheres em todo o
território missões internacionais também
recentemente tivemos na noruega 2016
como equipa a apoiar os adeptos
portugueses imigrantes e e não liga não
é grande temos uma multiplicidade de
influências
procuramos buscar todos os cargos
detalhes todos os estratos sociais e
crenças religiosas
estamos como piloto transborde social e
é por onde conquistamos 150 anos de
existência
estamos também grande vive em grandes
eventos ainda no mês passado tivemos um
exame para o ano voltaremos a ter sua
santidade o papa ainda recentemente
tivemos aqui no portugal-espanha euro
2004 ainda hoje é frio
internacionalmente como uma boa prática
portuguesa é seguir por outras polícias
de nível internacional e portanto todos
estes eventos que colocam no olho do
furacão é e se nós não tivermos uma rede
social
a próxima e com bastante dor as nossas
mensagens de segurança não chegam
facilmente a estratégia passa por
humanizar a figura do cristo
três das crianças de três animais
através da nossa escola enfim um sem
número de de idéias que procuramos
passar para a nossa página
porque no fundo da policia de pobre
renda provocada pela lista dos polícias
vêm do povo efetivamente a uma
estratégia e também de colocar o país na
nossa página
cascais madeira porto guimarães braga é
temos visto grafia não só da gente
policiais mas também civis que ao verem
sua fotografia na rede social da psp
também ficam também se congratulou e
interagem conosco forma positiva
é questão dos animais é fundamental você
se vê naquela fotografia está o
presidente da república é o nosso
cachorro de totalmente a visibilidade
estava instalada e está comunista da
missão interno nosso diretor nacional
esta questão de produzir querem tornar a
polícia com óculos talvez o momento mais
fechada não não aceito isto mas o que é
facto é que o próprio presidente da
república é a adop gest é que estão hoje
em dia fazem parte da cultura urbana 202
pré 200 e também de jovens e adultos e
nós também procuramos é fazê lo é
incluem compressão em alegria em guaíba
e proximidade com a comunidade que
servimos que toda portanto todos os
espaços etárias dos mascotes as duas
interessantes sobre como é como mascote
e representei apresentação visual de uma
marca é e como é que a questão dos
bonecos das ilustrações mesmo em adultos
é talvez não suporta a nossa infância
mas é muito efetivo utilizarmos a
questão das cotas estão o do quarto
turno para fazer passar a nossa mensagem
neste caso foi às vésperas do ano
passado do sporting benfica o jogo que
esperava problemático é e e não foi a
outras mensagens procuramos passar a
primeira polícia do mundo das aventuras
100% e ecológicas
tal questão de jogarmos em figuras
públicas para também criar alguma
proximidade mas também é a realidade nua
e crua da vida e sentimentos em cenas da
madeira nacional da psp da madeira ter
um trabalho também muito muito meritório
e grande sacrifício e abnegação
mas nós esse lado mais negro mas mais
difícil mais duro nós não escondemos nós
procurando publicado
é também para que as pessoas a comer a
de que temos
também lembro do risco é que os polícias
não estão sujeitos 24 horas por dia e
365 dias por ano
vamos agora numa viagem sky por alguns
de nossos posts mais criativos cantor
além daquela que é a informação a
profissional os dados o universitário do
comando
a visita da ministra há um sem número de
idéias que podem executar uma
instituição policial na altura nós
perdemos várias marcas estavam é ligar
se ao 21 de outubro 2015 quando o dobro
nem imagina que vai chegando o futuro e
nós fizemos procuramos também estar
nessa senda estão dando star wars muitos
poderão perguntar mas talvez associar
atrizes força pública star wars extra
será positivo ano tendo em conta as
reacções e o fitec nós devemos sim eu
acho que é positivo
neste caso basta o dito parece vindo das
nossas fileiras três novos cursos e
programas que também de forma criativa é
ter o livro a publicar isto quando
começámos a ver aqui uma janela de
oportunidade de criatividade é lógico
que há regras a uma barbárie
institucional à hierarquia mas isso em
termos de equipa do gabinete
ambos brainstorm ciência tudo discutido
primeiro que o posto seja lançado
[Música]
o óleo é normal
isso foi o que é uma pequena ação
fizemos vendo é no auge e lembrando star
wars the force one
criamos o videoclipe de final embora os
nossos patrícios nosso esforço foi
engraçado ver como este filme serviu
para a comunicação interna motivacional
de internamento mas também para o
público externo termos uma do audi star
wars tutela com a imagens reais da
polícia de segurança pública
o céu é o limite cai se o tema mais
comentado no twitter 2016 é o game of
thrones porque não fazemos um postal
silva que mostrou nos não frida tanto os
dogmas da instituição mas montando a
personagem principal e e aqui foi que
nesse ponto começámos a ser mesma
notícia na mesma os players de marketing
e marketing e publicidade briefing
citando de forma positiva como uma
instituição quase com 150 anos pode
estar nas redes de forma criativa
há outros exemplos de 1 de abril
simulados que me sair do facebook
tivemos inclusive muitos seguidores
ezequiel iniciar uma petição é caso nós
saímos e só depois é que se viram que
era mentira
carrie underwood cairo nossa nosso
troller
foi engraçado ter essa interação pessoas
vagam à página mesma série a e temos
muitos problemas muitas imagens de ver
indignação mesmo até dia 2 ou 3 de abril
este foi um gato que faro é chegar a uma
cotação de canaviais e acidentalmente
enunciou sem querer é 22 agentes de
investigação criminal em faro portanto o
drama do cianorte uma pessoa ligou para
a psp de faro a dizer covil miar
estridente do gato não estou matar um
gato
eu quero a polícia aqui foram 12
a investigação criminal chegaram a seu
apartamento não vi um gato mas viram uma
plantação de cannabis uma coisa ele
também na sala
o gato não apareceu mas aproveitámos
esta é a oportunidade real de fazer um
pouco de criatividade ser publicamente o
gato é com com farda policial como
justiça em tudo que é um microfone 2016
a china ronaldo decidiu atirar ao lago é
também arriscarmos é exposto aqui
primeiro que vocês foi alvo de algum
algum grande história em algum
pensamento será que ela vai falar com
vara ea reação foi positiva
temos a limitação da cntv e neste caso
nas redes sociais o time e é fundamental
se a nossa estratégia a série narcos é é
atualmente uma das séries mais
comentados mundialmente e também
aproveitamos para fazer uma uma ilusão
porque é o momento de acordo com o
global peace index portugal é o quinto
país mais seguro do mundo mas não sei se
esforçava isto há pelo menos 200 jovens
adultos sabem isto nós procuramos com a
uma usam a série narcos informar que
vivemos num país seguro é não graça só a
psp gnr pj conserta uma série de outras
forças e serviços de segurança
dar a conhecer esta informação de forma
diferente ea página é nada oficial e
interagiu com nossa página comentando
com um bife do pablo escobar
outros nomes como pokémon gol fizemos um
guia de segurança presta esta nova
realidade aumentada
tivemos alguns problemas com isto nada
tem de 600 pessoas 700 reunidas nos
passos sem aviso prévio à câmara a psp é
problemático para nós
nós tentamos antecipar com kong de
segurança do estudo dirigido a todos é
da caça época mundo
é isso o brasil vai encontrar uma uma
imagem continental e com o céu é no
início do ano a polícia judiciária
feijão comunicado a dizer que estava a
aumentar caso de sexo chã grande porte
ou seja o gráfico vingança instrução
sexual online
é nosso dever informar isso mas forma
criativa tem o mercado de imprensa da
polícia judiciária
penso que não não chegou a tanta gente
comentou
e quando isso acontece quando há essa
interação com esta partilha pelo menos
várias as pessoas a refletir antes de
enviarem uma má no dou uma postura mais
ousada que pode ser usada pois no futuro
para ser chantageado
penso que realmente estamos a contribuir
para essa prevenção preço ou hérnias
própria carta por pontos também foi um
dos nossos posts mais comentados a
autoridade nacional de segurança
rodoviária informou que as alterações a
carta dos pontos é mas nós tivemos carné
na cola carbatti e colocar lá informação
é e foi foi engraçado ver toda a
interação todas as partidas que este que
se posicionou pela necessidade partilhar
o conhecimento das pessoas ficarem logo
saber tudo sobre a casa dos contos
outras informações mais corriqueiras que
não chegam ou seja pelo nascimento
institucional do contacto roberto pt
outro fórum também procuramos conhecer o
sentimento da black friday
temos uma série de possibilidades
não não é aquela que é nobreza é
institucional da polícia turca mas as
redes sociais não for de forma diferente
a mensagem não passa no nos termos
acordados
temos diversas campanhas ocorrer temos
campanhas planeadas natal páscoa e
podemos previamente antecipar mas mas há
muitas já muitas idéias surgem virais em
redes sociais e nós tentamos adaptar mas
elas também aproveitamos para divulgar
nossos problemas estou aqui programas de
inclusão para crianças que estará agora
em dezembro é também aberto a idosos com
o portador de alzheimer mas como disse
no início toda essa e virar toda esta
opção caia em saco roto se não formos
genuínos no terreno
se não estivermos juntos as pessoas no
terreno pelas pessoas e para as pessoas
desde 1967 a fórmula tem de ser cai
sobre a
[Aplausos]